what's up Charles I'm good I saw where
you started up a little bit last night
where you talked about Golden State and
Durant and they wouldn't be a dynasty
without him and Shaq chimed in a little
bit here so you've had some time to
think about it you really believe that
they wouldn't be a dynasty in Golden
State if they didn't have Kevin Durant
dan anybody knows anything about
basketball know that if Durant leaves
there be a good little team but they
won't be he made them a dynasty and
there aren't a lot of pressure do you
know they've moved into that brand-new
building next year and they need Kevin
Durant I mean everybody's like what he
decided would Kevin Durant because they
need Kevin Durant he's the one who made
them a dynasty and so it's a lot of
pressure on that whole organization but
why is draymond Green reportedly saying
to Kevin Durant we don't need you we've
won without you leave like it what gets
what gets him to that point of a guy
that you know you need if you're gonna
win championships that draymond Green is
saying that to Kevin Durant well first
of all I don't really believe that
number one number one he said it I think
he just said it in a moment but listen
you hear all these guys be who we making
up these stories they want us to believe
that once one going into overtime that
dream on says you need to make up your
mind on free agency I don't believe that
at all they want us to think that in the
middle of a basketball game at the end
of a game is get ready to go over
overtime
dream on says hey you need to make up
your mind on free agency I don't believe
that at all okay Charles what did he get
suspended for because they know that
they got to appease Kevin Durant that's
why that's what makes it then nobody
gets to spend it when teammates get to
fighting in him could that happens at
least once a week with teammates getting
to or coach them out of years that a
coach
say things you regret the reason they
suspended dream on is because they know
that dynasty if Kevin Durant leaves is
going to come to end and people got to
realize they're going through that
brand-new big ol building next year
they're charging twenty thousand dollars
a seat on the front row people don't
want to stay if they want to see a team
as a just a nod they don't want to see a
team that's pretty good that's why this
has been a dream on did the Warriors
make it worse by suspending draymond
Green well that's a great question Dan I
think I think they are caught between a
rock and a hard place
they've got to look at their team this
year and they've got to look at the
future so I asked a great question I
don't know the exact answer but I think
what they did was they're like yo man
you can't make this do mad he's the
reason we had dynasty and we lose him we
just have a good team we won't be
favourites to win the championship every
year and I also I'm sure I don't think
Durant stays at Golden State but I've
thought that for quite some time now I'm
just curious where he would end up and I
know Steve and I Smith said the Lakers
or the Knicks I don't know if Durant
would help LeBron achieve even greater
success by going to the Lakers to help
him you know maybe win a couple of
titles instead of maybe doing something
unique like going to the New York Knicks
what what is the best destination do you
think if he doesn't stay in Golden State
well you know I don't know the answer to
that I mean these guys it's totally
changed now
it started with LeBron go on and then I
go on to Miami so everybody's just
looking to stack their teams now and
dominate so I don't know the answer to
that question you know you know we all
hate it when Kevin went to the Warriors
because exactly here we go as they
happen it's really funny you know
everybody don't want to go back and look
at the pens like man why is he going to
the Warriors that's gonna make them
unbeatable and they've been unbeatable
so but these guys now what would you you
want to play together what would you do
I want I want to stay in Oklahoma City
that's my
huh okay but now what would you do if
your dream uh you know that's a great
question I think I think he noticed he
knows that the Warriors has proposed
casitas and at some point money matters
at some point money matters in to the
Warriors they're like well we got to
give clay to max probably this summer
mm-hmm dividend we got to get Kevin to
max then next year we got a pager a mine
like at some point you can't pay
everybody I mean you know I know they're
in the luxury threshold but can you
imagine like putting another three to
four hundred million dollars in the
luxury tax I mean at some point you do
have to have some financial common sense
where do you think Carmelo ends up I
don't even know what's a great place for
him then to be honest with you the way
he he didn't he wants to play the way he
played five seven years ago where he
isolation him the ball and he doesn't
have those skills anymore so I'm not
sure what's a perfect place for him
right now
you know because I say you know he
complained like I know he started
laughing last year when they like we
want you to come off the bench you know
Dan when you get older as a player you
have to make concessions
plain and simple you're not the same
player ain't like it was ten years ago
in New York we just give you the ball
and let you go one-on-one when you were
a Greek and he was a great offensive
player they're not gonna things aren't
gonna play like that anymore
so it's gonna be interesting where he
decides to go I also wanted to ask you
about the Duke freshman that you know we
see these kids and I mean they're men
certainly with as I own Williamson but
you you see what how he plays now what
translates to the NBA do you think with
Zion Williamson can he be that kind of
player in the NBA
I don't know Dan cuz I don't know what
position we plays you know I think
that's going to be the key and you hear
these guys talked about world the NBA's
position list
yeah it's somewhat positional is but
some of these guys are still 16 6 11 so
at one point he's going to play those
other guys on the other end of the court
so number one he is way more explosive
than I was
I wonder what his real height is you
know because all these college players
lie about their height so I wonder how
tall he really is but I think the
biggest thing gonna be what position
he's going to play in the pros I know
he's on to Rick he's a terrific terrific
talent but he has to guard people on the
oven
did he guard threes out on the floor can
he guard a 610 guy in the post I mean
there's two people always talked about
one end of the court but there's two
ends of the court
how's he gonna figure how's he gonna
play against somebody's big old guys
he's gonna have to play against them
it's easy to put against these some of
these college players but an MBA we got
some players I'm just curious about his
weight if he weighs this as a freshman
right
I mean you dealt with this it is he
gonna be able to be this kind of player
at 300 pound mean he's to 85 right now
you know when people talk about me and
him like my weight was fat though when I
went from 300 to 250 my weight was fat
weight I don't think he's got fat weight
on him I think he is physically
physically amazing and gifted so I like
I say I don't I don't know if it's
possible for him to lose 25 pounds like
it was easy for me to lose 50 pounds cuz
I was fat but him like I'd have to sit
I'd have to look at his body up close
but he doesn't look he looks amazing but
like I said I don't think he's a guy
who's gonna lose twenty thirty pounds I
don't think it's there
I also saw that you guys you and Ernie
are gonna be working the match with
tiger and Phil what what role we have
play what do you know about golf well I
know everything about golf I mean that's
easy
I mean Golf is man I watch more golf
than probably anybody in the world I'm
addicted to the Golf Channel I mean I'm
not I mean I'm not good at golf but this
tour is just the terminology and hidden
cuts and fades and hooks and draws and
beams like that that's very easy but
they asked me in order to do something
and I listen I'll be a good team player
and do something in Vegas all right
who wants to win more do you think
between Tiger and film ah great question
from my ego standpoint I don't think you
can decipher that I think they both want
to win just from my ego standpoint
because they had this rivalry and you
know Tiger wood tiger the first of all
I've already said I think Tigers the
greatest golf who ever lived
he's the goat and it's just been
exciting watching him play this year
because he brought excitement back took
off
I mean bought a ton of excitement back
to golf it was awesome to watch and I
think that he wants to win just to keep
his domination going his confidence but
also I think field wants to beat him so
I'm gonna know the answer to that course
I'm looking forward to it it's gonna be
awesome I mean they're gonna be awesome
I mean you get two of the greatest who
ever did their thing you got the
greatest who ever did and Tiger I think
it's gonna be awesome to watch just
mano-a-mano who's going to talk more
trash between those two field is more
natural at trash-talking I think that's
what he probably has I think he has the
advantage as far as he's a lot more
social you know one advantage he had the
tiger head there's not going to be a
crowd on the golf course there's no fans
invited to the golf course so he can't
interact with fans and
field can't interact with fans and tugs
crashing have fun like that so that's a
disadvantage for him but like I say
because that when I play I played that
golf course like actually a couple weeks
ago there's no room for fans out there
so field can't just joke around with
fans and and Tigers personality he's a
lot more laid-back and low-key so I
think Phil has advantages for his
talking trash because it's more natural
to him he's a more he's a more fun guy
to joke with wouldn't it be great if
they started wrestling like in the 9th
fairway like king you know he started
going at each other and who would who
would you have if it's Phil versus
Tigers you got two guys who can't fight
so it would be a boring loss laughs fast
I don't think neither one of them either
or neither I'm not sure what word I
would use
I don't think either and neither has
ever been in a fight in their life ever
either one of them I think you're up
listen I wouldn't go out on a limb
neither one of those guys have ever been
in a real fight in their life I would
back that - I think yeah yeah I'd be
serious one of them ever been in a fight
in their life maybe you could ask that
to them when you and Ernie are they're
part of this winner-take-all Friday
after Thanksgiving maybe that's a
question which I and Pat Perez don't be
there also see mu L so samuel l.jackson
and pepper is I think it's gonna be
doing I mean obviously we're not gonna
be serious golf announcers I like I
don't know the exact extent of my role
but listen I'm just going at a have fun
that's all that's all it could be if I
said you got to put a week's pay on who
will win well I would they don't feel
because last time I saw the odds it was
like 150 yeah so you got a I'm not going
bet uh-huh fitted I'm not I want to bet
I want them going with two eyes so Tiger
is pretty heavily favored so from a
common-sense standpoint I would take
feel just because of
well thanks for joining us as always and
have fun out there in Las Vegas and stay
away from the the crap table and all
that stuff all right have fun in love
and don't go gamble I'm gonna gamble
when I'm in Vegas
a hundred percent all right well say
hello and goodbye to your money for me
okay hey brother you know I always tell
people gamma gamma is a 50/50
proposition you're either gonna win are
you gonna lose that's 50/50 I'll take
those odds Thank You Charles you too
that's uh Charles Barkley for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show ass
[Music]